here we are folks and if ever there was
a time where the pressure was on for a
movie to be good this is that time men
of Steel this is gonna be a spoiler free
video here so you have nothing to worry
about will I do a spoiler filled video
you bet I'll put that video up in a few
days probably this weekend but for now
enjoy the spoiler free review so we all
know what Man of Steel is by now it's
Superman dude it's directed by Zack
Snyder Zack Snyder gave us 300 Watchmen
Dawn of the Dead that that movie it's
produced by Christopher Nolan so things
are looking good for Man of Steel and
it's an origin story so we could see
Krypton again I liked how Krypton was in
this movie you get a sense of Krypton is
more than just a big white ice planet it
has a system it has a culture it was
cool to see and they spend a bit of time
on Krypton more time than you expect
which is why when little kal-el ship
gets to earth it immediately cuts to him
being an adult you see his childhood
upbringing in the form of flashbacks I
always like that that's a time efficient
very interesting way to tell a story if
you do it right that is you jump to him
being an adult you get the cliff note to
him being a kid and you see the relevant
events of things that matter cool
Superman in this movies played by Henry
Cavill I've always called him Henry
Cavill because it just sounded cooler I
guess it's cavil either case doesn't
matter he kills it as kal-el he's really
good in the role the dude looks the part
he's likable he's relatable as a person
can still tell he has like moral fiber
he's like no I got to do good cuz I'm a
good guy but he's not unrelatable you
know he's a good guy like a good guy on
earth could be a good guy the dude is
human he grew up on earth - his genetic
code guys pretty human he's human but
he's really good and he's assertive he's
not a pushover he's just he's what I
wanted Superman to be in this movie
other than Henry Cavill everyone else
did a really good job in the movie - Amy
Adams was good as Lois Lane Kevin
Costner as good as Jonathan Kent I was
afraid it was gonna feel like Costner
was shoehorned in this movie but it
didn't he felt like Jonathan Kent II
felt like a good Jonathan Kent Michael
Shannon is Zod is the one that I'm like
he was cool in the movie I can't say
Michael Shannon owned the role you know
you want to walk out of a movie like
this and be like that actor was the only
actor who could have played that role I
don't feel like that with Michael
Shannon and General Zod it kind of bums
me out that being said he was awesome he
was intense he killed it in the sorority
letter and he did a good job in this
movie one of the fears I've heard about
in this movies people are afraid that
they're trying to turn the Superman
franchise into the dark
night franchises Nolan's producing this
and he directed the dark night movies so
automatically I get it it's a fear it's
out there but in this movie now clearly
Zack Snyder directed this movie whether
or not you like Zack Snyder will
determine whether or not you feel like
that's a good thing
but at no point this movie was all like
Christopher Nolan directed this movie
cuz it didn't feel like that Zack
Snyder's a very visual type person you
know however in Zack Snyder being a
visual director sometimes when the
throwdowns happen between Zod and
Superman or kal-el as they call them in
this movie which is also awesome at
first you're like okay that's really
cool awesome I like it then you're like
okay they're all flying through
buildings and it's still intense and
cool then at a point you're like okay
you can kind of back it up you don't
have to make everything so exaggerating
crazy in terms of some of the action
sequences in this movie I feel like less
could have been more I mean I like cool
action sequences I like Superman I want
to see Superman and General Zod fly
through buildings because that would
probably be cool but I also like
fireworks I like the fourth of July but
every time I watch a firework show
that's like a half an hour long by about
minute 10 I'm like okay I get it I'm not
gonna see anything new here I feel like
kind of the same thing happened in the
action sequences in Man of Steel
don't have to have a crazy action
sequence and then followed up with
another crazy action sequence and then
follow it up with another crazy action
sequence at a point you start diluting
the currency and it starts becoming less
special there's a part of me that thinks
Zack Snyder watched a bunch of Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers episodes and they
get their swords and they're knocking
each other around and the monsters are
falling on buildings that are getting
annihilated his ex night it was like
well I can wreak more buildings than
that watch I'm gonna do Superman the
setup in this movie has a lot of
information to cover in that you feel
like the first hour this movie's a bit
chopping the sense that they're like
alright this this this this this this
all right now caper now he's flying
however when he flies it was awesome
because he doesn't just fly like yeah
I'm kal-el I fly because that's what I
do
you grew up on a farm in Kansas so what
would the expression on your face be if
one day you got the power of flight yeah
just like this movie where he's like I
got his thoughts of a fly it was cool to
see I like the fact that he acts human
so this is a cool start for a Superman
franchise I walked out of this movie
going alright I want to see a sequel
hell I want to see a Justice League
movie I want to see where they take this
universe the reasons I'll talk more
about my spoiler video but for now I
liked it I loved Henry Cavill the first
half of the movie felt a little choppy
at times and as cool as the action was
in this movie at a point you're like les
would have been more that's
undeniable for me however cool [ __ ] does
happen you can't deny that I will say I
will buy a Man of Steel on blu-ray I
suppose if I can tell you to keep
something in mind when going in to see
Man of Steel it's that the tone that
they've set up for the past year via the
trailers isn't really the tone of the
movie no the trailers have had these
really tragic songs like the first one
had the song when Gandalf fell into the
shadow and fellowship at the ring and
you're like dude this movie's gonna
emotionally wipe me out not really you
do have emotional moments in the movie
but all in all the fourth trailer the
trailer I didn't actually do a video on
know the action-packed type trailer
where you're like alright that looks
like awesome some are moving us which
isn't a word but it is now that
action-packed trailer is more or less
the more accurate depiction of man is
Dale so Superman movies what's your
favorite what's your least favorite
whatever they are comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more